welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and this video
we're breaking down Iron Man 2 I want my
bird though the film is often cited as
one of the weakest entries in the MCU I
think as part of the whole it works
brilliantly the movie introduces new
characters sets up things to come and
also shows Tony at his most vulnerable
point after binge watching the MCU a
definitely thing that the film improves
in several ways and hopefully this video
shines it in a new light for you
throughout this we're gonna be going
through some of the easter eggs in the
film that don't pay off until much later
in the franchise this isn't every single
easter egg but there's a lot on here
that I haven't seen mentioned in other
videos so I do hope you enjoy it
obviously there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't had a chance to
watch all 23 films and the infinity saga
then I highly recommend that you turn
off now make sure you subscribe to the
channel as we do videos like this every
day and please drop a thumbs up if you
enjoy the content without the way thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
our breakdown of Iron Man 2 okay so up
top before we get into the details I
just want to talk about the villains of
the piece Iron Man 2 is often criticized
for having lackluster antagonists but
both not only serviced the plot in
several ways they also reflect aspects
of Tony's personality Justin Hammer is
basically a self-obsessed businessman
who tries to use his charm and charisma
to further his career he's a womanizing
scoundrel and don't you just bloody love
him he's attempting to build his own
version of the iron man's suit and he
copies Tony in several ways to his own
detriment
unlike Tony he's unwilling to put
himself in the firing line and whereas
Tony spent hours in his workshop
innovating new designs in technology
hammer simply steals them from others no
more is this shown in the line by hammer
where he meets Vanko and the two discuss
their plans hammer orders some food and
says that he likes to eat dessert first
if you've checked out I'll get out
breakdown and you'll know that food in
films is often chosen for characters
specifically and get out Rose ate cereal
separate from milk showing that she
didn't like colors mixing with her idea
of whiteness
hear hammers choice to eat the dessert
first shows that he wants instant
gratification and pleasure without
having to work for it he's basically the
arrogant side of Tony without the talent
to back it up however that doesn't mean
that Tony is perfect and Hammer similar
to Killian an Iron Man 3 did initially
want to work with him but he was brushed
to the side and ultimately this created
a rivalry on the other side of the coin
Vanko is a genius who was reduced to
almost nothing and similar to Tony and
Ironman whan he used his skills to come
back and was able to build something new
however a vengeance overtook him and
thus he succumbed to it another common
misconception that I've seen send it
around both Iron Man and spider-man is
that they're villains in the MCU have
been created by Tony this is often a
criticism that's level towards the
spider-man films as Pete attends deal
with the repercussions of Tony's actions
however in this film we learned Tony
actually inherited his initial tubulins
similar to how spider-man does later
down the line both Steinem Vanko were
created by Howard stock and then Tony
had to deal with the sins of the father
Tony is a father figure to Peter and
this this repetition of him inheriting
his initial two villains is a nice curry
over one thing I also didn't really
notice until history watch either is how
much Thanos and Tony actually marijuana
know they're both are heavily concerned
with resources and sustaining life in
the long run Tony wishes to use the arc
reactor to do this in the film in order
to make clean and sustainable energy for
the planet we see this journey through
the MCU to the point he believes he is
saving the earth by creating Ultron
Ultron ultimately ends up deeming the
world and this is similar to how Dan
asked believe that he was saving the
universe by carrying out a snap but as
we learn from endgame it had left all
life in a state of despair
so both had good intentions but they
ultimately ended up going about it the
wrong way
however Tony was able to come back and
do the right thing whereas Thanos was
not an Iron Man one
Tony states that the best weapon is the
weapon that you only have to fire once
and that is of course what Danis does
when completing this snap Stark also has
a weapon that we learn he can only fire
once which is a laser beam that takes
out all of the drones this laser is also
used only once in civil war when Tony is
fighting against Buck
cap and in endgame in the final battle
there's also an incredible line in the
film uttered by Vanko who after fighting
Tony at the Grand Prix states if he can
make God bleed people will cease to
believe in him
Dallas was thought to be God like an
infinity war and almost unbeatable
low-key at one point said that he would
never become a god but after his journey
of completing six tasks and resting on
the metaphorical seventh it became clear
that he was however in infinity war Tony
was able to make Danice bleed and he
even acknowledged it by saying all that
for a drop of blood we've seen zack
snyder's 300 then you'll know the film
ends in a certain way and similar to
that this shows that it is possible to
be Danis because if he can make God
bleed people will cease to believe in
him anyway that's a long-winded way of
talking about the themes and parallels
in the film the movie itself opens in
the wake of the Ironman press conference
not long after this Tony met Nick Fury
in his home he uttered the line you
become part of a bigger universe you
just don't know it yet and this was
murdered in his meeting with spider-man
and far from home and which he told him
that he was part of a multiverse so he
initially told Ironman he was part of a
bigger universe and in far from home he
told spider-man that he was part of
multiple universes Tony and Peter are
the only Marvel characters to get two
films in the same phase as well
cementing that spider-man will indeed be
taking over the reins of the franchise
going forward Vanko watches the stark
press conference on TV and his father
passes away angered by the treachery of
the Starks who left his family to die in
poverty he begins to build
now shoutouts to Jaret Hamilton who are
my last Iron Man video pointing out that
this scene echoes the cave scene from
the first film
Franco hammers away and creates his own
version of the suit using arc reactor
technology which we learned his father
co-created with Howard stock there's
also a shot of bread and butter over a
blueprint perhaps symbolizing that they
made their bread and butter through the
arc reactor we learned that after Howard
learned vanko's father only wanted the
reactor as a means to get rich he had
him deported so this bread and butter
could be linked to that beber reach but
you know me that's what you here for
were also introduced to vanko's bird
best bird in the MCU do not at me Falcon
cut to Tony about to drop in on the
stark Expo and we here shoot to thrill
by ac/dc in Iron Man 1 we were
introduced to stock through back and
black by the band and this is a nice
progression for the character I also
don't know if this is intentional but
the dances surrounding a hero and almost
parading him reminds me a lot of the
star-spangled man from the first Captain
America movie from here we learn that
Tony has palladium poisoning this is due
to the arc reactor in his chess but it
could also been pushed into overdrive
due to Pepper releasing palladium gas
and Iron Man in order to destroy the
reactor we see a presentation by Howard
stock which is meant to resemble the
Epcot presentation by Walt Disney tony
is called to go to the Senate hearing
which is led by Senator Stern we learn
that he is a Hydra agent in the Winter
Soldier and also meet Justin Hammer who
states that Tony has created a sword
that he says is a shield this could be a
reference to Captain America who
primarily uses a shield as a weapon but
it could also be a nod to the Marvel
Group sword and shield from the comics
Tony hijacks the video feed and plays a
hammer demonstration in which someone
gets twisted in a suit and yikes that
looks like it hurts in Doctor Strange
strange turns down a case for a 35 year
old Air Force colonel who severely
damaged his spine in experimental armor
though this was often thought to be
Rhodey it was denied by Marvel so is
possible that it's the person we see in
this footage we can also see on Tony's
phone an app for the Illuminati which is
a superhero group in Marvel Comics Tony
also throws up a peace sign which shows
how far he's come from the first film in
that he made fun of someone throwing up
one in the funby and then upon exiting
the cave he threw an up to signal a
helicopter overhead Peter reappears here
and in age of Ultron he says all he
wants his peace in our time it's also
what he says to cap when trying to
bridge the gap with him in endgame we
then cut to the workshop and see the
versions of the Iron Man suits we can
actually see above the Mach 1 that it's
a reconstruction and this is how he has
it in the workshop after it was pretty
badly destroyed in the first film Tony
also hangs up an Iron Man picture which
is a play on the Obama image we see this
being sold at the end of the Avengers
and it's nice to see a girl from here
into the
film he appoints pepper as a CEO and she
asks if he's been drinking to which he
replies chlorophyll this is actually to
counteract his palladium poisoning and
the effects that it has on his body when
telling her this he says he tried to
figure out where he successor and then
drops the line it's you it's always been
you this line would reappear an end game
when he records a farewell message to
pepper after believing that his time was
up we also see a hint of the iron man's
suitcase in the scene - its nicknamed
the football which is a reference to the
presidential briefcase that has the
launch codes for nuclear weapons in it
Banco meets with a member of the ten
rings who as we know were the villains
from the first film and they're led by
the mandarin happy hogan practices
boxing with tony and this is a callback
to his origin story in which he was a
boxer store clerks of Natasha's zoo or
the Natalie's resume and we can see that
she has hammer industries on it which
could show that she was also trying to
infiltrate his company in Monaco they
meet Elon Musk
who says he has an idea for an electric
jet in the next scene we see that tony
has already invented this and that he's
beaten him to the punch should have
invented a bad name for your door am i
right
Christine Everhart from iron man shows
up and we learned she's doing a big
spread on Justin
and that she did a big spread for Tony
in the first movie I seen that the
photographer also takes a picture which
appears in the avengers in stock tower
Vanko shows up and gets the suit and I
didn't notice this but a keen relative
spotted that the suitcase had a foothold
on the other side showing that Tony
could deploy it either way
Ranko attacks stock suit with
electricity and this causes a lot of
problems with it in these breakdowns we
always talk about how Tony learns from
his mistakes and in order to combat this
he clearly puts measures in place to
absorb this in the future this is how
when Thor attacks him in the Avengers it
overpowers the suit instead of
completely wrecking it this was also
used as a way to attack Thanos in
Avengers endgame
Tony beets venko he drops the guard line
is saved by hammer and taken to meet him
this actually happens at Elon Musk's
SpaceX facility and you should have
called your daughter SpaceX am i right
how're also refers to himself as a
benefactor and this is why many people
believe he may be the mysterious
operating behind the scenes in ant-man
in the wasp also yeah give the man his
birdie a just he just wanted bored he
also begins building drawings for a
hammer and utters the line that I love
drone better though Tony didn't
initially do this in Iron Man 3 we see
he's enabled his suits to have drone
capabilities at Tony's party stuff Goes
Down and he and war machine fight it out
the fight goes through the ceiling and
when they come back down we actually see
Natasha almost blow her cover as she
adopts a martial arts stance when this
happens this show she's ready for a
fight in such a scenario they crossed
the streams which of course plays into
how they defeat Benko at the end were
already flies to an Air Force Base and
we also see the soldier from the first
film remember him
he's called Allen anyway he's back to me
with the character Tony meets with Nick
Fury and black widows cover is revealed
they then go to his home in Malibu and
we see Tony sitting in the same robe
that a young Howard wore in agent Carter
Hammer sells weapons to build war
machine and this is how Banco is able to
infiltrate his systems we also see a
missile known as the ex-wife that would
make Ulysses look like it was written in
crayon this shows the lack of hammers
knowledge as Ulysses was actually
written in crayon to help James Joyce
see it Tony goes through a briefcase
left by his father and we can also see a
copy of Captain America issue 1 Tony
plays back a film reel from his dad that
contains his final message to an adult
Tony he's passing on a message to the
Future and the way that the projector is
set up plus Howard's final stance when
delivering this echos Tony's final
message at the end of an game that was
played on a projector within the helmet
and it was left to Morgan Tony's child
much in the same way that Howard left
this for his child Tony I would love it
if we were visited the moment from
endgame with Morgan later in the series
and saw that she had a secret message
from Tony to as it would really
symbolize the passing of the torch this
being a message from both characters
from beyond the grave is very poetic and
shows how Marvel loved to carry across
symbolism in Howard's manual we also see
a cube and that is the tesseract Howard
found this at the end of Captain America
the First Avenger and we learned that
he'd been working on it in endgame when
Tony traveled back in time
Tony goes to a roadside stop with a guy
selling strawberries he says he doesn't
like people
handing him things and this is a motif
that's stuck with the character he did
at the start of the movie and avenges
when me in Coulson and the only time
that he doesn't really mind it is when
his father hands and flowers in endgame
also shouts to filleth from reddit who
pointed out that the watched Tony trades
for strawberries is actually the one
that Obadiah gave him in the first movie
he goes to see pepper and get that thing
off the desk also we see Bill O'Reilly
who completely slams pepper verbally
harasses her and yeah this scene has not
aged well we also see a cover of Fortune
magazine which a young tone features on
and this echos the initial presentation
at the award show on the character in
the first film
Tony creates a new element and when
doing this we also see the Captain
America shield from the prior film this
was behind Tony as the suit was
dismantled and here it's used on a pipe
no wonder these guys fell out in Civil
War also Tony Danza black vest when
working on it and this is of course a
callback to Iron Man worn when he was in
the cave and also endgame when he was
working with nebula he creates a new
element and heads to the stock Expo
where Justin Hammer is doing a
presentation on his new drones we see
the hammer logo looks a lot like the
kingdom of Asgard and the company is
also called hammer which yet could be a
very subtle nod Timon yeah the press
faces a different problem because
they're about to run out of ink writing
how good this video is and we see the
drones which go haywire and start
attacking people also a nice little
addition is that when the war machine
armor is hacked the writing and it
changes to Russian I'm sure you've also
seen this one before but just because it
ties so heavily into the MCU we really
can't miss it out the boy wearing an
Iron Man mask is indeed Peter Parker and
this was confirmed by foggy as a fun
little Easter Egg Black Widow and happy
head to hammer industries and we see
Natasha taking down multiple security
guards in the Black Widow trailer we can
also see taskmaster studying a tape of
this in order to learn her fighting
styles and moves Widow reboots the war
machine armor and the hammer drones land
Tony does the dodge move from a missile
which we saw him do in the first Iron
Man film went facing off against the
tank they managed to take them down
hammer is arrested and he tells pepper
that he will be seeing her again soon
and
could be setting up the benefactor roll
down the line Tony and Rhodey fight
Banco and we also see stock he's the
smaller dot rockets that he did in
Ironman one they managed to take the
villain out by crossing the streams and
the former ends up saving Pepper after
the drones triggered a self-destruct in
Iron Man Tony and pepper shared a scene
on a balcony where they didn't kiss
however here they do bring that scene
full circle the film ends with Tony
seeing the Avengers initiative as he
meets with fury in the background you
can also see a map that has several
locations including New Mexico Greenland
and more Wakanda is hinted out which is
of course the home of black panther
Malibu is highlighted which is Tony New
Mexico is Thor Greenland for Captain
America and Virginia for the Incredible
Hulk senators stern gives Tony and
rhodium medal and Hale Snyder ac/dc
highway to hell plays over the credits
and this could be handing out what's in
store for Tony down the line or it could
just because it's an awesome song anyway
that's our list obviously I'd loved hear
your thoughts on the breakdown and if
there's any Easter eggs that should have
made it comment below and let us know
and if you enjoyed this video then
please drop a thumbs up and make sure
you check out our breakdown of Iron Man
which is gonna be linked at the end I
think it's one of our best videos ever
so please give it a watch after this if
you want to support the channel from as
little as 99 cents a month then please
click the join button below
we massively appreciate you and it's a
thank you you get access to content
early you want to come chat us after the
show either follow us at heavy spoilers
or click the discord link in description
below those the best ways to keep up to
date so hopefully we see over there very
soon
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thank you for taking the time to watch
this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you